charlemagne the god here leonard
mckelvie and i am ready to play most
likely drew
i mean it's always like the comedians
right especially the the the women
comedians you know miss pat
you know tiffany haddish
those are the ones that are really
speaking truth to power in a real way in
a way that you'd be like ugh
you'd be uncomfortable like but that's
good like i i can't think of too many
female comedians we've had conversations
with where you just don't be like
i don't know if you supposed to say that
in 2021 but i
great content
that's such an interesting question a
lot of rappers don't like come in the
studio and just be like you know
spitting bars off the top of their head
or even mumbling to themselves you would
think that would be the case but
i don't see that too often i have a
theory about that though i think it's
because um nowadays
a good conversation
can sell
records probably
better than a good rap can so i think
when they come to the studio to do
interviews they're just automatically in
that mode of conversation as opposed to
that mode of you know performing as
artists
[Music]
every single rapper you could think of i
mean name them like run down the list
like i don't even know the last time a
rapper has been on time it's like when a
rapper's on time you'd be like oh
okay
you know dope congratulations i'm glad
that you you know decided to show up
[Music]
maybe because i just saw her but issa
rae we had issa ray on
um a couple weeks ago oh ava duvernay
too like you said he said like they just
walk in looking very regal like like
very like just everything everything put
together
amazingly from the shoes to the belt to
the hair to the accessories
[Music]
oh man i mean they very right like i've
had the pleasure of interviewing
everybody from you know president barack
obama to young thug and you know for me
if i'm sitting down with you building
with you for you know 40 minutes to an
hour i'm engaged i couldn't even think
to narrow that down to one person we had
dr sanjay gupta on this weekend
we built with him for like an hour and
sharon was on that is actually you know
a friend of mine in real life especially
when you're talking to like people that
are really your folks like folks you
hang out with outside of you know radio
or podcast or tv folks you actually like
go to their house and kick it with them
those are always very engaging to me
because you don't want to violate the
friendship so to speak you don't want to
overstep the boundaries of the
friendship because there's things you
may know that you could probably say
but why
would you do that
you know what i mean we live in this
cancer culture era and you know i've
been doing radio long enough to know
when somebody may say something that's
going to get them in trouble i'm the
type of person now man back in the day
i'll be like yeah let that fly
for the ratings for the youtube views
whatever but now it's like
nah
let's pre let's protect you know that
person
[Music]
most improved 100 i like who i'm
becoming i like the journey
i'm on you know going to therapy
in
2015-16 was one of the best things that
i ever did and it just got me on you
know a healing journey for me it's like
yeah i would definitely give a myself
most improved i like who i've become as
a man it's made me a better father
better husband a better friend because
i was a wild boy
wow boy
drew thank you for having me um i really
appreciated being on the show i can uh i
can feel your energy you're very
interesting unique
human who has
an incredible story and you've been on
quite the journey and i just want you to
know that the journey
is not over in no way shape or form you
have a lot to offer this world and you
have a lot to offer
the universe and if i can be of service
to you in any way shape or form uh
lennard mckelvie charlemagne the god is
here for you so peace
[Music]
you